[Música]
y
i
[Música]
ah
en alguna parte
[Música]
cabrero y the school
su canción falsa
[Música]
con el reto de dormir o en algún lugar
que nunca vende
descongelación de muerto en la misma
vanidad
[Música]
cuéntanos todos
síguele quiere verte con él
[Música]
éste exige tu atención
manipula todo tu restando
[Música]
ahora
en sala
bueno
me ves
sí no
en mi vida
[Música]
e
o no
y más
para mí
[Música]
[Risas]
nada
[Música]
a
ah
si va más allá de lo que tienes
más allá de cualquiera
sólo tú bebé
esto no es así
[Música]
ah
muchas gracias muchas gracias y muy
buenos días a todos qué tal estáis
nosotros estamos encantadísimos de estar
aquí un año más somos es java y esto que
hemos hecho era supernova y ahora vamos
a tocar verte bailar y esperamos que
aunque sea muy temprano que os animéis
que es sábado lo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy caminamos transparentes miras de que
el mundo quiere subir a llorar
[Música]
esta bajada
y esas palmas
[Música]
y me pagó
sólo me bailar
no
o no
vivir
solo
hoy en día es que está subversiva quiere
subir a la vida quieres vivir
como en casa
[Música]
para
no
y no
i
sólo dime de bailar
d
sí
[Música]
y
personalmente jamás
[Música]
no
hoy no voy a fallar
plan está preparado
ya
otras dos de dos líneas mi voz ligeras
sólo está salvada
sí no
i
[Música]
y me salvó
solo al verte bailar
nada logrando casi me paro solamente
nada
hoy
[Música]
totalmente
muchísimas gracias que disfrutéis de
esta primera parte de télex gracias